one of the most disturbing scandals has
been the infection of thousands of
people across the nation with HIV and
hepatitis C through contaminated blood
today Lord Penrose publishes a report
which follows nearly 25 years of
campaigning by members on both sides of
this house to address the scandal could
the prime minister as the last acts of
his government ensure a full apology
transparent publication and above all
proper compensation for the families
terribly affected by the scandal my
honorable friend is absolutely right to
raise this with the Penrose report
published today and I can do all of the
three things that he asked for I know
that many members on all side of this
house have raised the question of
infected blood I've spoken about how
constituents have been to my surgeries
while it will be for the next government
to take account of these findings it is
right that we use this moment to
recognize the pain and the suffering
experienced by people as a result of
this tragedy it is difficult to imagine
the feelings of unfairness that people
must feel of being infected with
something like hepatitis C or HIV as a
result of a totally unrelated treatment
within the NHS and to each and every one
of those people I would like to say
sorry on behalf of the government or
something that should not have happened
no amount of money can ever fully make
up for what did happen but it's vital we
move as soon as possible to improve the
way that payments are made to those
infected by this blood I can confirm
today the government will provide up to
25 million pounds in 2015-16 to support
any transitional arrangements to a
better payment system and I commit that
if I'm Prime Minister in May we will
respond to the findings of this report
as a matter of priority finally Mr
Speaker I know that Lord Penrose was
unable to present the findings of his
report today because of illness and I'm
sure the whole house would want to send
him our very best wishes